good morning my name is Pippa Mills and
I'm the deputy chief constable in Essex
Police I'd like to read a statement to
update you on a live murder
investigation being led by the force
following the tragic discovery of 39
bodies inside a lorry container this
morning shortly before 1:40 a.m. today
we received reports that a number of
people have been found inside a lorries
container at the water glade industrial
park on Eastern Avenue in Gray's we
believe the lorry is from Bulgaria and
came into the UK through Holly Head on
the 19th of October emergency services
attended but sadly all 39 people inside
the container had died early indications
suggest that one of these people was a
teenager the rest are believed to be
adults a murder investigation was
launched and the lorry driver a 25 year
old man from Northern Ireland was
arrested on suspicion of murder and
remains in police custody at this stage
we have not identified where the victims
are from or their identities and we
anticipate this could be a lengthy
process I would like to thank the local
community and in particular those who
have been directly affected by the
police cordon at the industrial site
thank you for your cooperation and I
appreciate the impact the road closure
will have on businesses within the
cordon I'm unable to say at this stage
how long the cordon will be in place but
please let me reassure you that my
offices and partners will be doing
everything they can to release the scene
as soon as possible this is an absolute
tragedy and very sad day for Essex
Police and the local community we will
continue to work alongside many other
partner agencies to find out what led to
these deaths I'd like to appeal for
anyone who has any information to
contact my offices at the major
investigation team on 101 or by visiting
our Essex Police website we will update
all of our channels as we're able to but
please appreciate we're in the early
stages of what is likely to be a lengthy
investigation
not at this stage and obviously the
identification of the victims remains
our number one priority so that we take
you to the scene what led you to go to
the scene to investigate and we received
a call from the ambulance service taking
a similar to that I'm not sure that
information at this point in time not at
this point in time said it's the early
stages of the investigation but
obviously that will be a key line of
inquiry and as I've said if anyone's got
any information relating to that lorry
and its movement since entering the
country on the 19th of October then
please do contact us on 101 it's very
early its stages it's a complex scene
and we've got expert officers working
with partners at the scene to identify
it and that the best way forward to do
that in terms of the identification of
those those individuals this morning
thank you very much for attending here
as soon as we have updates we'll make
them